Donald Trump and Rudy Giuliani are
accused of plotting to sell presidential
pardons as Trump's time in the Oval
Office was winding down for the very
affordable price quite frankly in
context of 2 million dollars a piece a
former staffer says in a lawsuit we've
already discussed the uh outrageous
sexual assault allegations that are part
of this lawsuit from former Giuliani
Stafford Noelle Dunphy earlier in the
show I now want to focus in on the
presidential pardon part there's a
Business Insider article that summarizes
this quite well on Monday Rudy Giuliani
was hit with a bombshell rape civil
lawsuit filed by a former staffer the
staffer alleged in the lawsuit that
Giuliani asked if she knew anyone who
wanted to buy a presidential pardon the
suit says Giuliani said he was telling
them selling them for two million
dollars splitting the profit with Donald
Trump